body cam footage has come out of the
police officers who responded to the
scene of the shooting in Nashville and
went in and it's genuinely heroic stuff
it's very hard to watch some of the
videos because it's body cam I mean
you're seeing the Carnage that's taken
place in the school but
parts of it are a little easier to watch
than others and these guys just
conducted themselves with such heroism
professionalism courage skill it's it's
the opposite of uvalding where the cops
were just chatting around outside too
cowardly to go into the school in fact
trying to stop other people from going
into the schools was a complete disaster
made law enforcement look terrible and
in this case these guys went in just
like the absolute top tier kinds of
First Responders and they they deserve a
medal they deserve Flawless and law
enforcement which has gotten really bad
rap in recent years at least in
Nashville law enforcement should be
looked on as the heroes that they are